[Música]
es el último bastión de la humanidad
antes de la Inmensidad del Atlántico
como olvidada 25 km de la costa de
finister hueso es una isla agreste y
fascinante
antiguamente era tierra de Navegantes de
larga distancia ahora el finisterrae es
uno de los últimos barcos de pescadores
profesionales de La Isla a bordo o undin
hija y nieta de un pescador perpetúa la
tradición familiar
desde pequeña navega en esta parte del
océano muy profunda y particularmente
rica en plancton aquí tenemos verdaderos
torrentes submarinos con corrientes muy
fuertes somos Afortunados porque estas
son las corrientes que dan vida y son la
base de la cadena alimenticia más que
las pescas milagrosas son los panoramas
de hueso los que iluminan los días de un
Din un privilegio que le gusta compartir
con el resto del mundo
estoy haciendo un pequeño Live para
gente que no tiene la oportunidad de
estar en hueso
siempre es un placer cuando puedo
compartirlo con suscriptores en Facebook
la belleza natural de la isla y el
aislamiento de su comunidad Esto es lo
que caracteriza a Wesson en su pequeña
tienda en lowport en el corazón de La
Isla ondin se encuentra principalmente
con clientes habituales es bastante
agradable todavía no somos muchos en
invierno tenemos una población Aquí
somos alrededor de 400 habitantes en
enero y febrero y entre ellos Joshua el
padre de ondín apodado finch El pirata
este antiguo Marino mercante ha viajado
por todo el mundo su ronda matutina
siempre comienza con la tienda Casi casi
32 años estoy jubilado
Yo soy quien le transmitió el demonio de
la pesca dicen que para aferrarse a esta
tierra alejada de todo un poco salvaje
se necesita temperamento escucharé como
respiras de acuerdo conoces esto Qué
suerte el único médico de La Isla tiene
en abundancia originario del continente
se aventuró a hacerse cargo del
consultorio del Antiguo médico general
hace 5 años
no podía haberme regresando a un
consultorio de rutina cotidiana quería
estar un poco aislado hacer un poco de
todo hacer un poco de emergencias
medicina
una vez que probé wessant realmente no
me vi trabajando en ningún otro lugar
Así que esperé el momento adecuado para
sentarme aunque no todo sea sencillo
pero ahora me embarqué en la aventura
las consultas abundan para robatitis
debe estar disponible las 24 horas del
día y aquí Él es mucho más que un médico
el médico hacía todo en ese entonces
veterinario obstetra lo que quieras
siempre es un poco de todo el repara el
cose es el MacGyver de La Isla
de La Isla los días son largos todas las
tardes el doctor Bass visita a sus
pacientes
al principio tuvimos que adaptarnos a
los hábitos de hueso no hay nombres de
calles y tienen la mala buena costumbre
no sé de no poner su nombre en los
buzones como todos se conocen
No es solo el médico quien juega a Los
Ángeles de la guarda
en esta Isla que ha visto tantos
naufragios hay nada menos que cinco
faros dos en tierra y tres en el mar
aquí son apodados los héroes de hueso
toma la corriente Aquí vamos un poco más
allá muy poquito Gracias
fotógrafo aprovecha el pequeño oleaje
para captar el reflejo del Faro de
suroeste de hueso un momento especial
tenemos el reflejo ahí tengo el reflejo
logré conseguirlo vamos a tener que
aclarar algunos lugares porque bueno es
hay algunos que no están mal
hoy tranquilo el mar en hueso Se parece
más a menudo a esto o las potentes y
peligrosas a veces de 30 metros de
altura Dominique Se enamoró de la isla
por las severas tormentas invernales que
ponen a prueba los faros unos fareros me
explicaron que antes de que una ola
rompiera en el faro oían venir La ola y
era como una caja de resonancia dentro
del faro es un ruido enorme a veces los
muebles todos se estremecía dentro del
faro al igual que Dominica El fotógrafo
a un Dean la pescadora le gusta
compartir su amor por los faros
somos tan cercanos a nuestros faros que
los consideramos Héroes como si fueran
verdaderos seres
una vez a la semana un Din les cuenta a
los turistas la historia de estos faros
el más antiguo tiene 300 años la más
reciente un siglo han guiado a
generaciones de marineros en esta Costa
implacable cuando veían la costa de
buzón era porque estaba demasiado cerca
de Susana es decir si vemos huesos
estamos demasiado cerca y podemos quedar
atrapados en las corrientes los escollos
frente al Atlántico en los confines del
continente Los Héroes de hueso vigilan
sin tregua y dan a su Isla ese carácter
único